Mẹ hai thống bây giờ, tư lận lực lượng có phòng thái lan đã từng sông quyết đủ
các đi khẳng định mục tiêu của bằng cóc là VWC hòa bình bến dưới và sơ mở lại các cơ hồ về các phu tría để
đạo thật lợi cho thương mại và đi lại.
Phát biểu khi thị sát cảnh cửa đôi trọng mũ ở tình trọng rài đã từng sông quyết đến mạnh,
việc tăng cường đối thoại sông phương thông qua cơ trễ hiện có như quy bán biệt dời khu vực, quy bán biệt dời hút hợp và
bình dưới chung là tần thiết nhằm giảm càng thẳng giữ hai nước, giúp bất vụ khi tâm xa và đưa lực lượng cho
lại trọng thái như năm 2020, đàn bảo an toàn trong người dân hay bên.
Ông cú khảo định thái lan cảm két tần thủ, mừng tắc nhìn đạo trong xử lý và này bình dưới.
Theo dưới chức phòng phái lan, khiện hoa đau phối hợp quân xử dự vân cóc và phần nông pân đã được cả két nó dễ,
với việc vui chỉ tổng ra chung và lần bữa tôn.